okay and I am proud to introduce Francis
you who's going to be presenting her
dissertation work
she Francis has a bachelor's in
Biochemistry and cell biology and a
master's degree in bioscience and health
policy from Rice University
in Houston she has participated in a
wide range of research from wet bench to
clinical trials to health policy to
systematic reviews
for the Pacific Northwest EPC she has
drawn to cancer research particularly
the Precision medicine and predictive
analytic initiatives her interests led
her to clinical informatics and she
hopes that her research will contribute
to responsible use of EHR data for
research so welcome thank you for
presenting today thank you
welcome everyone thank you so much for
being here and today I'll talk about a
potential application of cause of
inference to pancreatic ductal
endocarcinoma patients EHR data
to start things out this just review
some pros and cons of randomized control
trials or rcts and observational studies
so rcts randomizes patients to different
treatment groups and this minimizes
potential confounding and other types of
biases
however rcts are often criticized for
its short duration so instead of
following up patients to important
endpoint outcomes sometimes the only
follow-up to surrogate outcomes that may
or may not be important to patients
rcts usually also have a smaller sample
size so it lacks the power to conduct
subgroup analysis
and it is extremely high cost so
sometimes it may not be feasible or even
ethical and for these limitations there
is a limited generalizability of
findings from rcts to the overall
population it is estimated that about
five to ten percent of cancer patients
actually meet the inclusion criteria to
be included in an RCT so what do you do
for the rest of the patients that are
not studied in an RCT
so on the other hand these limitations
of RCT are generally advantages of
observational studies where they have a
large and diverse sample that can
examine the subgroup
so for example this is intervention work
better in older people or in younger
people or in men versus women
and refill reflects the real world
setting better
it usually has a longer follow-up and
because of its larger sample size we can
study rare Adverse Events
but observational data are susceptible
to biases such as selection and
information bias and the database may
not contain information of
interests such as or performance status
and lastly it may be difficult to find a
good control group for your
observational study
so our CT traditionally seen as the gold
standard is only on level two of the
strength of evidence because you're not
going to just trust results from one RCT
and call it good what we really want to
trust is the systematic reviews of
multiple rcts pointing to all similar
findings
now when you don't have systematic
reviews or rcts then you have to go to
observational studies such as
non-randomized control cohort or
follow-up studies
but what happens when we examine
observational studies versus rcts is
when we in these two meta-analyzes those
two study groups found that only about
two-thirds of cancer treatment
observational studies agree with rcts so
what they did was they took rcts of
about a dozen different Cancers and then
they matched observational data from the
National Cancer database and then
matched the patient inclusion criteria
to these rcts run the analysis and then
compare their outcomes and then about
two-thirds of the time the observational
studies agree with the rcts
some researchers have proposed potential
reasons for this discrepancy between
rcts and observational studies so there
could be a difference in populations
such as what kind of patients are given
specific kind of treatment in
observational study versus being
randomized in RCT or interventions are
more tightly regulated in RCT and
patients are follow up more tightly
versus in the real world setting
patients may not follow their
intervention
strictly as an RCT
and there are another limitation to
traditional registry is
that data as we mentioned before are
sometimes limited and they may not
contain the details that you want so for
example we all know this your data the
cancer cancer database and for data
collected between 1975 to 2020 radial
therapy and chemotherapy are only coded
as yes or no unknown there is no
specific details about what chemotherapy
agents was given or how much radiation
dose was given
and the registry also like treatment
sequencing data so we don't know if the
systemic therapy occurred before and or
after surgery which is a hot topic of
research right now
and the National Cancer Institute
recognized that their biases associated
with measured reasons for whether
patients receive or not receive these
systemic Therapies
so EHR data is a potential solution to
this limitation because it offers more
granular data for research
as we know there's a really prevalent
EHR adoption now in the U.S that
supports a steady increase in number of
Publications researched using EHR
however there are new sources of bias
identified in EHR data that we're just
uncovering right now so for example
informed presence bias or where sick of
patients they sicker patients offer more
data in the EHR
and I'll show you here
where X our exposure of interest for
example ultrason Spectrum
disorder and why our outcome of Interest
GI issues and N can be seen as a
representation of how often they are
encountered in the healthcare settings
so if they have more encounter then they
are more likely to have more
documentations
and x0 is the likelihood of having
documentation for the disease X and Y
zero is the documentation for having the
outcome of Y of Interest
so in our first scenario here B1
even if your diagnosis or outcome I'm
not related to whether or not you're in
the Health Care System just simply
having more encounter in a healthcare
system means you're more likely to have
diagnosis of
either x 0 or y0 and this can be seen as
a confounder
so this confounder causes this various
association between your exposure of
interest and outcome even though
Upstream in reality there may not be
this Association this is caused by this
income founder
and we know that people who have AST are
more likely to have more clinical
encounters which then makes them more
likely to have documented GI issues in
their EHR data again also causing this
potentially experience Association
now on the other hand circular patients
having more data could also mean there's
actually
less likely to have an event so
a couple EHR studies found that patients
with type 2 diabetes who underwent
bariatric surgery appears to have a
better cardiovascular outcome than
diabetic patients who did not have this
surgery they tried to replicate it in a
couple of small rcts but they did not
find any benefit
so Russ and it all tried to investigate
what is the potential reason for this
discrepancy between rcts and
observational studies so first they
tried to replicate earlier EHR studies
where they compare in type 2 diabetic
patients patients who had bariatric
surgery versus those who did not have
the surgery and again they found this
quite significant
benefit in cardiovascular outcome
but they surmise that it is because
Bariatrics patients are followed more
closely and for a longer period of time
and so they have more document in the
EHR
and versus other diabetic patients who
may not be followed as closely may not
have as longer follow-up in the EHR data
that they're using and so they have just
less data and when they do encounter
the healthcare process again it may be
because they have a major health event
such as a cardiovascular event so they
try to find a better control group so
these are when they compare type 2
diabetic patients who had bariatric
surgery and then they compared to
diabetic patients who under underwent
elective hip or knee arthroplastic
surgery then they did not find any
difference or benefit in cardiovascular
outcome
it's because these two groups are
tracked similarly have similar medium
time to follow up and any cardiovascular
events are equally likely to be recorded
there are also hidden social biases in
EHR data and these data are being used
to train algorithms that could harm
patients in the future
so Urban Meyer evolve examined this
algorithm that assigned risk Force to
patients and for patients above certain
threshold they're assigned a nurse
coordinator to help them coordinate
their complex Healthcare needs
but open my red all found that at any
given risk or so for the same risk score
black patients are considerably sicker
than their white counterparts
and I found out that this is because
the algorithm use healthcare costs as a
proxy for health status so instead of
really investigating what is a true
health status of these patients they use
healthcare costs and we know that black
patients have multiple barriers to
access so as a result their Healthcare
spending is lower even though they are
just as sick as their white counterparts
and this algorithm
perpetuates this bias so sicker patients
are given a lower sacred black patients
are given a lower risk score and as a
result they're not assigned this nurse
coordinator who could help them improve
their
health status
so to quickly summarize there are
several issues with using EHR data for
clinical research when there is a lack
of catalog of potential biases in nehr
data
as as we know now there are hidden
social biases as a result of the
healthcare process that are embedded in
the EHR data and this issue it cannot be
simply solved by just getting amassing a
larger volume of data or collecting more
data you have to investigate and ask
your data do I have this potential bias
in the data and try to find another data
set that does not have this bias and do
your sensitivity analysis to see if this
bias exists in your data
and researchers are uncertain how EHR
data biases affect their analyzes
so to realize the full potential of real
world evidence such as using EHR data
for research we need to identify
potential biases and develop methods to
mitigate these biases in order to draw a
more valid conclusion from EHR data
so how can we improve inference from efr
data when rcts are not feasible or
available
I would like to propose using pancreatic
cancer as a use case to explore this
question
pancreatic cancer overall including
multiple types ranks 10th in terms of
incidence but third in mortality as we
all know it is quite a severe disease
and median survival is about nine months
because over half of the patients are
diagnosed with stage four metastatic at
the time of their diagnosis
so
and pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma or
pdac is the most prevalent form of
pancreatic cancer accounting for about
85 percent of all pancreatic cancers in
PDI patients about 15 to 20 percent can
undergo resection
or surgery so you talk about some terms
so when I say resectable interchangeably
with operable it means the cancer
portion can be surgically removed
borderline resectable or borderline
operable means the solid tumor has some
contact with my major blood vessel but
it doesn't prevent the surgery it's an
in-between case
neoadjuvant therapy refers to chemo and
or radiation therapy given before the
surgery
and overall survival or Os is our most
interested outcome is time duration from
diagnosis or treatment possible death
notices a busy slide so I just want you
to focus on this part is in patients who
can undergo surgery for pain for pjac
the guideline recommends they can go
directly to surgery first or they can
choose to have some systemic neoagen
therapy and then followed by surgery
for borderline
patients as well it is generally
recommended to receive some neoadjuvant
therapy before proceeding to surgery
but even the guideline committee
recognizes that their the value of new
adjamin therapy is still evolving and
we're not 100 sure how much benefit
should all patients receive adjamin
therapy or should they go to surgery
first
and because pancreatic cancer progresses
so quickly and most only 15 to 20
percent of patients can undergo surgery
it is really difficult to investigate
this question of whether patients should
receive a new adjuvant therapy or go to
surgery first
and there are about five or six trials
that fail to recruit sufficient number
of patients to answer those questions so
it's only in 2020
this is the first phase three RCT
adequately powered to study this to
answer this question
the priapank one trial was conducted in
the Netherlands where they compare
patients who receive
a single agent chemotherapy plus
radiation before going to surgery or
going directly to surgery
at about media follow-up of 29 months or
just over two years they found that
there is no difference between these two
groups it has a ratio about
0.78 MP value of 0.96
but as I mentioned this was conducted in
the Netherlands so there's some a little
bit of treatment difference compared to
how we treat pediatric patients in the
U.S so in the U.S we typically give a
two or three drug regimen depending on
patient's tolerance
and that's different from the kind of
chemotherapy regimen they gave in the
Netherlands so now this trial is being
replicated in the U.S the creopank 3
trial and it's expected to complete in
2024.
so again how do we improve inference
from ESR data when rcts such as the one
we just looked at are not really
feasible or they're lacking and we don't
have multiple of them to confirm whether
or not there is a benefit for having
systemic therapy before surgery
am I proposing a solution is to apply
causal inference to pdot patients EHR
data that may help us answer if patients
should receive new adjuvant therapy
first or proceed directly to surgery
I'll quickly touch on causal inference
so it's a better potential solution to
better utilize EHR data for research and
draw causal conclusions
it is a broad scientific framework with
Landmark Concepts and includes Concepts
and tools to analyze these observational
data
and then one important component of it
is a correct model specification so you
need to specify and indicate your
assumptions and your model communicate
it to other researchers before you
analyze your data
and a tool to communicate your model and
assumptions is using directed acyclic
graph or gag
in a dag there are these nodes
that
help you categorize your variables such
as as an exposure or outcome
and these arrows or edges actually
represent causal relationships so in
this dag I'm saying that this exposure
causes the outcome
we're mostly familiar with confounders
I just noticed I the error is the wrong
way I'm so sorry so it comes under it's
actually a cause of precedent to the
exposure and outcoming that a confounder
causes both the exposure and outcome so
the relation from your exposure to
outcome is not because there may be this
actual relation but it may be just
because you're you're including this
confounder
that's causing both of these
now there are mediators which is how
exposure could
act on the outcome or cause the outcome
acting through this mediator
if you control for this mediator as you
control for confounders you're actually
eliminating this indirect path of your
exposure on your outcome so you're on
probably underestimating the effect the
total effect of your exposure on your
outcome
there's also a moderator that or effect
modifier and lastly and most importantly
perhaps is Collider
so in contrast to confounder a collider
is a causal descendant of your exposure
and outcome
usually the collider path is closed
because as you can see both Arabs
Collide on this collider variable so
the path is closed between the exposure
and your outcome
but if you control for a collider as if
it's a confounder then you open up this
backdoor path and now you
here
introducing a spurious Association into
this exposure outcome relationship that
may not be there
so to answer my questions I'm proposing
three specific angst they're just my
research question
first this will conduct a systematic
review on critical biases in EHR data
and generate and generate an organizing
framework
two is to identify
pdac treatment decision process that
contributes to Patient selection for
each type of treatment regimen
and finally to construct a causal model
emulating the preo pink one trial with
EHR data bias entry mis-election factors
and validate the model
this is just a general framework to
conceptual framework to show you how aim
one and two feeds into the aim three of
constructive and validating the causal
model
so for aim one I'm proposing of
cataloging critical biases in EHR data
and first we're asking what biases are
unique to or Amplified in EHR data to
answer this question will conduct a
systematic review of biases identified
only in nature data or less known biases
highlighted by EHR data
we will catalog these biases using
existing framework so using
epidemiological categories of bias and
source of bias in EHR data pipeline we
also use thematic analysis to propose a
new organizing organization of biases
this is the inclusion exclusion criteria
for the systematic review it is
intentionally broad to capture as much
information as possible
and generally not limited too much
except the study should examine EHR data
specifically and not traditional
registry or administrative data and I we
are limiting it to countries with
widespread EHR adoptions such as the US
Australia Netherlands because we once we
do not want to include bias in countries
where what kind of patients could have
access to the healthcare system that
hasn't EHR data that's a whole other
form of bias
writing two first there are three
subparts
first we want to identify prognostic
factors for pdac and this will come from
a literature review of published review
articles within the last five years
the second part we will attend
pancreatic cancer tumor board up and
observe pancreatic cancer team aboard
and from the tour we want to know what
prognostic factors and other factors are
discussed in the multidisciplinary
meeting to craft a treatment strategy
for pediac patients
and these three parts will inform our
third component which is key informant
interviews to identify in the
observational setting what kind of
patients get assigned or recommended to
what kind of treatment
so our key question here is what factors
do clinicians consider intuitively or
analytically when recommending treatment
to patients
this is based on the Dual process Theory
where when we're making a decision
there's some uncertainty
if it's a
well-known recognized
scenario that we have experienced with
then we're more likely to use our system
one or intuitive thinking where we just
recognize pattern and then we make a
decision
but in more uncertain scenarios we may
slow down try to collect more
information analyze them analytically
and then arrive at our conclusion
so this theory proposed that in general
we
sometimes we use just system one and
system two access of monitor to make
sure we're applying the correct pattern
recognition to answer our question and
sometimes we rely more on system two
especially when the situ situation is
complex or uncertain and we have not
encountered it before
so for this sub part of aim2 we will use
propulsive sampling of key informants so
at least two clinicians each from
medical oncology and Surgical Oncology
because potentially other
sub-specialties will be interviewed or
interview at least six and up to 10
clinicians or onto a constant saturation
to ensure the trustworthiness of careers
identifying these interviews will use
data triangulation so in addition to
interviews we're also using varied and
multiple sources such as from the
published reviews and from team record
observations
we'll conduct member checking during the
interview to ensure accountability of
the factors identified during the
interview
and our study team will discuss and
breach consensus on during content
analysis so make sure that different
investigators agree on the same coding
and themes
which will lead me to the final aim to
construct and evaluate a causal DAC
so here on the left side is as a result
of aim one
the biases that we have identified in
EHR then we'll investigate if those
biases are in the OHSU
patients CHR data and if they are they
will conceptualize these bias as dag
variables to indicate in our model
on the right hand side is our summary
from A2 where we'll map prognostic and
treatment selection factors to data
elements in the EHR
both of these will come together into a
causal model and will fit it with
structural equation modeling and I'll go
into more detail about the model
validation process
so first just to briefly go over what
kind of patients were
looking to recruit into this
retrospective
review
we'll work with the oak tree research
data warehouse team to develop a curry
and extract structure eh data elements
and we also reference pathology and oral
surgery database of patients to ensure
that we capture then complete cohort of
patients
our patients will be limited to those
age between 18 and 89 years to have
underwent Patriot to me at OHSU between
2012 and 2022
so here's my sample size calculation
with the Opera Hazard ratio of 0.75
giving a conservative conservative
estimate that about 20 patients may not
have sufficient data I address you the
minimum sample size required is 545
and Oak Tree cohort Discovery suggests
that they're about 690 patients that
made this inclusion criteria at OHSU so
we should have sufficient sample size to
conduct This research
just
quickly going over the types of data in
potential elements that will collect
from the EHR and this will be augmented
by our aim to we into factors
so some of these data will come from
structure ESR data and some from manual
chart review
for structured ESR data we'll validate
them in 50 patients and make sure that
what we extract out of the EHR are
validated and also present in their
chart
and lastly after fitting the model we
want to see how valid it is so first
we'll do a overview of model fit to
statistics for conventional thresholds
if there's sufficient number of patients
and we'll try to do a cross-validation
holding out 20 of the patient population
fit the model with our training set and
Acquire The Edge strings and then fit
the model with our test set and evaluate
the difference between these using root
mean squared error
we'll also return to our interview is
from M2 and see how they think about
this model that we have developed based
on their input about its possibility
usability and is it comprehensible for
them
and last thing we'll come we'll Circle
back and compare it to the preo paint
one trial so first we'll compare the
unadjusted OHSU three-year survival rate
with the corresponding group in the
priapank one trial so we'll compare OHSU
patients who went directly to surgery
first to those who were assigned to
surgery first in the pre and pink one
well and those who had systematic
therapy with those assigned to the new
adjun therapy
then we'll compare the relative risk
between these two groups unadjusted in
the OHSU data and from the pure pack one
trial
and nothing will compare the model base
so adjusted relative risk of OHSU
patient data compare that to the
pre-permanent trial if there's
discrepancy between our
second comparison here then we
hypothesized that by using a model based
adjustment then we can get closer to
what's reported in the RCT
so preliminary search for biasis
Signature data have identified 687
records potentially 170 are relevant and
they are currently undergoing full sex
review articles I've already included 10
and excluded three up here
So based on these just 10 included
studies we're identifying multiple
biases in the HR data
this is categorized according to the
epidemiological definition of bias of so
we're familiar with confounding
selection bias and measurement bias
what I want to point out is that
traditionally missing data are not at
random is a measurement bias but in the
HR data if we're selecting cohort based
on this variable that's not missing at
random then there could be a selection
bias
and realizing based on these articles
that there's a lot of fuzzy biases in
EHR data that don't neatly fit into
these three categories which is why
we're proposing that we may need a new
framework to organize these biases
another way we propose to organize these
biases is by the HR data generation
pipeline so from care delivery all the
way to ETL and data analysis and
interpretation at the end
we're seeing we expect to see a lot of
biases in a care delivery portion so
including access to health care and
what's actually Inc recorded in the
clinical encounter what's discussed
during the clinical encounter so this
first step may be expanded in order to
really capture is it even before
patients reach the clinic and when they
reach the clinic what kind of healthcare
they're receiving
to review some products from this
research so from aim1 we'll have a
catalog of bias critical for research
using EHR data and a new framework to
organize these biases
from A2 will have verified factors
affecting treatment selection and
pediatric prognostic factors
and from A3 a causal directed acyclic
graph comparing neoadjuvant versus
surgery first in receptable and
borderline respectable pudact patients
and model validation results
is this my proposing timeline so we are
I have just resubmitted my IRB
application and we're doing the full
text review for aim one
Arabic lines there are some limitations
for This research so number one is
there's limited generalizability due to
organs population homogeneity
so we know that pancreatic cancer
disproportionately affects black
patients and they also have a worse
mortality rate unfortunately in Oregon
we have a really small black population
so using ohsu's data means it may not be
generalizable to the entire U.S
to mitigate this that this is why we
included a literature review that can be
published by any International
researcher so we're hoping that the
literature review captures a broader
patient cope
patient characteristics all around the
world
also there's
we recognize that it's a relatively
small sample size of clinicians
interviewed in aim to
so to supplement that we're also using
tumor board observations to identify
factors and also these factors are
proposed by clinicians who may not have
the time to participate in interviews
then we can verify these factors during
the interview with clinicians
and lastly there's a lack of patient's
perspective in treatment especially when
we really care about your decision
making and that would just be a topic
for future exploration and research
so in conclusion
EHR data offers potentially more
granular data than current cancer
Registries an appropriate use of PHR
data for research could supplement
evidence based in the absence of trial
data
applying causal inference to model
pediatic patients EHR data could better
emulate rcts
and the catalog of EHR data bias can
help future researchers investigate
potential biases in their EHR data and
address them appropriately in order to
draw more valid conclusions
I would like to thank my DAC committee
and which is your faculty and staff and
demise alumni
and be happy to answer questions
[Applause]
Lynn is Raising her hand when she's
monitoring the chapter thank you
that's correct
Tasha has a question
uh Tasha can you
speak your question or can Lynn we can
hear you if you speak
I I actually actually don't have a
question I just accidentally hit them
button sorry about that
so I have a question okay
um so you're going to be interviewing uh
clinicians in intube but you're not
going to be interviewing patients
the reason I ask is that sometimes I
think there are social factors that may
be part of the decision-making process I
mean I'll give an example of someone who
maybe caregiving may not be able to be
away from families so they may have
reasons that might not be documented in
the chart why they want to pursue One
Direction or another so is there a have
you thought about interviewing patients
as well
I have consider it
um
I think that would just explode This
research is already almost intractable
research already
I do know that
pages are taken into account during the
pan uh the terminal board discussion so
whether patients are motivated
um it's their ability to access care and
how easy they can do follow-up here
which is you are all taken into
consideration so some of their
preferences and perspectives will be
identified
okay thank you thank you
Eric yeah
um really great job I think this is like
a cool project and really clear I'm just
curious and I understand like this is
what you're doing
you're going to seem to preemptively
speculate a little bit but you know
you've been doing a little bit of
reading about biases that are more
prominent or Amplified in the HR data
and then you've also then acquired some
background knowledge on your specific
use case pancreatic cancer like do you
and again this is what's going to come
out during this project but what are
your
what are your current thoughts about
what looks like might be you know one of
the more impactful biases that exists in
the states that they're going to be
using okay
by the way can people online hear the
questions
yes we can hear
okay great thank you
that's a really great question
I think for pancreatic cancer here at
OHSU it may be the information bias so
how complete of information do we have
on these patients so if they just come
to
in his campus
if they just come to OHSU for surgery
but they have systemic therapy in their
Hometown before or after surgery then it
may not be documented in OHSU so now we
have a differential business best
classification of patients who have
their primary care and receive systemic
therapy here which is you versus those
who may live further out and do not have
this information documented
so this is a
what's a question more of a thought that
I had based on the response you just
gave I think it's going to be
interesting to see what differences
there are between the structured and
unstructured data for a lot of those
kinds of factors because that's the kind
of thing where you may not see it in the
structured data but it is likely that
it's captured in progress notes or
something like that the same thing for
patient preferences so
um
looking at kind of the
how informative the structured data are
or properly modeling this versus
including the structure unstructured
data should be very interesting
I kind of have a related
maybe unrelated questions Emerson
um so we'll fall into
um are there do you think that there are
going to be different perspectives or
even biases in terms of trying to
um because from tumor board uh a lot of
times various clinicians will probably
voice their opinion about whether
someone should get neoadjuvant therapy
or not
um versus when you do interviews and
past specific clinicians about what
these things are there existing do you
think there'll be differences
um in kind of the information you get
from
both from either one or are there kind
of existing
bias that we know from interview
research versus
um
I don't like a transparate from the
discussion
uh it's a little choppy for me to hear
so are you I'm just repeating as you're
asking if there are differences between
all the clinicians present at Timber
board and what they think are important
and what they mentioned versus the
clinicians we do include in our
interviews
right I think you'll be able to get data
from attending to my board
um but there and then interviewing the
clinicians you'll be able to get data as
well do you think they'll be
similar or do you think it'll be
different
you see differences in probably
clinicians who volunteer to be
interviewed are probably more analytical
and are willing to share their
thought process
um and so we are missing some data from
clinicians who may rely slightly more on
their intuitive thinking
and that is a limitation so we could
only verify what
non-interviewed clinicians thoughts are
with those that we interview but we
cannot do the reverse so to expand on
this project in the future we could
include surveys for clinicians who may
not have the time for interviews and
just check back with them to see these
are the factors that we have identified
and are we missing any or would you add
any just in a really quick survey and
not going through a whole interview
big
are there any more questions from the
audience
then do you have any other
um
any of people who are interested in
asking a question or have a comment from
chap
I don't see anything in chat
well I want to say thank you
[Applause]
so
um
this time we will clear the room and um
have a chat with professors thank you so
much